and
respecting anyone
I need to have an intimate
as confidential is between you and me do
you feel happy here of course I'm happy
here
aren't you
do you feel you know how she would react
in every situation
I've always had this fantasy that
there's something else out there for me
[Music]
do you want to live mundane lives or do
you want to be part of something special
and unique
you've been selected to live up there I
don't care what you're wasting your time
because we haven't even been on an
airplane I should I should clarify I'm
talking about you here junior
only you
[Music]
we're going to ensure hen has company
while you're away
we're going to replace you
[Music]
I don't want a robot living with my wife
I really want to leave her here all
alone day after day
he doesn't really see me anymore
maybe I shouldn't be telling you this
I encourage you to use the opportunity
to act on your instincts
thank you
what if we decide
be together
[Music]